in this video you're going to learn
about the discriminant and how to find
out whether a quadratic equation has two
solutions one solution no solution and
whether they're real imaginary and even
whether they're rational or irrational
so first of all what exactly is the
discriminant well you're probably
already familiar with quadratic
equations these are equations that are
in this form ax squared plus BX plus C
equals zero and you probably also learn
about the quadratic formula and what the
quadratic formula does is it allows us
to solve for these values of ax that
make this equation equal to zero and now
graphically what a quadratic is is it's
a parabola when you graph it and when
that parabola crosses the x axis those
are what are referred to as the zeros
that's what's makes this equation equal
to zero so you could have a parabola it
crosses at two points on the x axis one
point or not at all and so that's what
the discriminant allows us to do so the
discriminant is just this part here
that's underneath the square root in the
quadratic formula it's the b squared
minus 4ac and if it comes out to a
positive number meaning it's greater
than zero then we say that there's two
real solutions meaning it crosses the
x-axis at two points if it's equal to
zero then we say that there's a one real
solution meaning it crosses right at the
vertex so just one answer to this
equation and if it's less than zero
meaning that it comes out to a negative
number then we get zero real solutions
meaning that the parabola either opens
up or opens down but it doesn't cross
the x-axis so there's no real solutions
you actually get two complex solutions
we could say two imaginary solutions now
a bonus I put here is that if the
discriminant comes out to a perfect
square like 36 or 49 then what will
happen is you'll get two real solutions
but those solutions will be rational as
opposed to if it's not a perfect square
it would be irrational so that's kind of
like a bonus there let's do three
examples and then I've got a fourth
example that's more challenging so if
these ones are easy go ahead and skip to
that fourth question so a number one we
have two x squared minus three X plus
one equals zero we want to find out you
know what how many solutions are there
and what
are the solutions are they real
imaginary how many are there so the
first thing you want to identify is the
a value the B value and the C value okay
and you want to make sure everything is
on one side and it's sign equal to zero
then we're going to substitute it into
our discriminant the b squared minus 4ac
so let's go ahead and do that b squared
minus 4ac you want to make sure you
capture the sign whether it's positive
or negative so B is negative three
negative three squared minus four times
a which is 2 times C which is one so
this comes out to negative 3 squared
which is 9 minus 4 times 2 times 1 which
is 8 so that's coming out to 1 now what
the 1 means it doesn't mean that there's
one solution the one it's positive in
meaning it's greater than 0 so that's
this case right here there's going to be
two real solutions and because one is a
perfect square you're gonna actually
have two rational meaning like it's you
can written as a ratio of an integer
divided by an integer so we get two real
or you could say two rational solutions
and then parabola would look something
like this where it crosses the x-axis
twice for number two what do you think
for this one well this one's a little
bit more challenging because it's not in
this form where it's equal to zero so
what I'm gonna have to do is I'm have to
subtract the 8 from both sides of the
equation to put it into that standard
form now we can identify our a value
which is negative one our B value which
is positive five and our C value which
is negative eight and let's go ahead and
put it into the discriminant b squared
minus 4ac and that's gonna be let's see
5 squared which is 25 minus 4 times a
which is negative 1 times C which is
negative 8 and here we're getting 25
minus let's see this is a 32 now
sometimes need to be careful with the
signs so you'll have a negative 4 times
a negative 1 times a negative 8 and odd
number of negatives is gonna be a
negative if I had an even number of
negatives that's gonna be a positive or
plus so this comes out to negative 7 and
because the negative 7 is less than zero
that tells us that we're actually gonna
have two complex solutions or you could
say two imaginary solutions or you could
say that
no real solutions and your parabola
would look something like this where it
doesn't cross the x-axis so we'll just
say two imaginary solutions for this one
okay now you might be saying to yourself
Mario you know why does this work like
why are there two real or one real or no
real why is the discriminant work the
way that it does well if you look at the
quadratic formula which you usually
learn before you learn the discriminant
you'll notice that this quantity
underneath the square root imagine if
this came out to a negative number right
if you go to take the square root of a
negative number you really can't do that
you get an imaginary number right what
number times itself is a negative number
well it's not a real number right now if
this comes out to zero see the square
root of zero is just zero and if you do
negative B plus zero or negative B minus
0 since 0 is really like nothing you're
really just getting that one solution
the negative B over 2a and then the last
case is if this is positive then of
course when you take a square root of a
positive number you're gonna get a
positive number and it's going to be
negative B plus that quantity or
negative B minus that quaniee and you're
getting those two solutions so that's
why it works but it's basically a
shortcut to figure out how many
solutions that you have and whether
they're real imaginary etc so for number
three what do you think for this one
we've got 4 x squared equals 12x minus 9
if you're saying we need to get into
this form you're absolutely right
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to move the 12x either side or
subtract 12x from both sides I'm gonna
add 9 to both sides and equal to 0 now
remember whenever you move something
from one side to the other the sign
changes to the opposite now we've got
our a B and C value and let's go ahead
and put that into our discriminate b
squared minus 4ac so negative 12 squared
is a positive 144 a is 4 and C is 9 4
times 4 times 9 is 144 so we have a
hundred 44 minus 144 which is zero now
don't get confused you might say oh
there are zero solutions no when the
discriminant is equal to zero that means
that you have one real solution it would
look something like this where it
crosses the x axis just at one point at
the vertex so we're gonna say one real
okay before we jump into number 4 which
is a little bit more challenging
if you're new to the channel and we
haven't met yet my name is Mario of
Mario's math tutoring this channel is
all about making learning math less
stressful so you can raise your grade
pass your class and go on to pursue your
dreams so that's what we're all about
here if you're interested check out more
of my videos but let's jump into number
4 it says find a value for C such that
the quadratic equation 3x squared minus
2x plus C is equal to zero has two
imaginary solutions or what would C be
if it had two real solutions or what
would C be if it had one real solution
so we have to do a little bit of work on
this one you can see that a value is 3
the B value is negative 2 and we don't
know what C is so we want to do if we
want to find out if there's gonna be two
imaginary solutions that's when the
discriminant b squared minus 4ac is less
than zero so let's go ahead and write an
inequality we've got b squared minus 4ac
is less than 0 b squared is negative 2
squared which is 4 minus 4 times a which
is 3 times C which we don't know and
that whole thing has to be less than 0
or negative so we have 4 minus 12 C is
less than 0 we subtract 4 from both
sides that gives us negative 12 C is
less than negative 4 and if we divide
the whole thing by negative 12 C is
going to be greater than 1/3 because
remember when you divide both sides of
an inequality by a negative number that
inequality sign is going to flip or
change directions
so as long as C is greater than 1/3 it
could be 1 or 2 or 10 as long as it's
greater than 1/3 then you're gonna have
two imaginary solutions the parabola
would look like this where it doesn't
cross the x-axis okay for letter B
though two real solutions well two real
solutions means that this scenario here
it has the discriminate has to be
greater than zero so let's go ahead and
do that so we have B squared minus 4 AC
is greater than 0 so that's going to be
4 minus 4 times 3 times C is greater
than 0 and so that comes out to 4 minus
12 C is greater than 0 if we subtract 4
from both sides
and divide by negative 12 you can see
that C would then be less than 1/3 again
because we divided by a negative the
inequality sign flips so to imagine here
is greater than one-third two real it's
less than one-third what do you think
one real would be well setup that our
equation here b squared minus 4ac when
it's equal to zero there's one real so
equal to zero so again we have four
minus twelve C because C all these
values are the same and if we subtract
four from both sides and divide by
negative twelve you can see that C is
exactly equal to one third so if you
want to review actually finding not just
how many solutions there are but what
exactly are the locations of these
x-intercepts then you want to use the
entire quadratic formula and I talked
about that in that video right there so
I'll see over in that video